maybe the white suburban kids are proud
to be american but for the rest of us
who are
women
uh
the poor that woman is not she does not
talk like a poor person she talks like a
rich entitled white liberal
you're not allowed to say make america
great again i mean guess this gets to
the heart of our problem you're not
allowed to root for america you know we
don't even know what america is if you
if you say you want to make america
great again if you salute the flag if
you put your hand over your heart when
you say the pledge you are according to
the left engaging in white nationalism
because america's an evil rot in racist
bigoted terrible
white supremacist place
just take a listen to this voicemail
this voicemail was left on the the phone
of carter nordman he's a representative
state rep in iowa
this was a woman who who called him
because he supported a bill that would
have schools say the pledge of
allegiance in the morning just like we
all did when we were kids just like has
been true for a lot of american history
she
she got triggered
yes this message is for carter nordman
my understanding that you are the iowa
state representative who
included language that requires all iowa
schools to lead the pledge of allegiance
once a day in grades one through
twelve when did we start teaching white
nationalism in schools because that's
exactly what the [ __ ] you're doing sir
and you have absolutely no right to
require something like that
our children aren't proud to be american
maybe the white suburban kids out in
adel are proud to be american because
their rights are afforded to them every
day and they don't have to fight for
them but for the rest of us
who are
women
the poor the elderly uh the minorities
we're not so proud what are we proud of
we're proud of our racist history we're
proud of our racist roots
is that what we're proud of we're proud
of the fact that not all citizens in the
united states are afforded the same
rights and the same privileges as the
blond-haired blue-eyed ones
so
first of all that woman is the voice of
a generation before we make fun of her
before we talk about how kooky and crazy
she is she is espousing what is now the
mainstream point of view that if you say
anything nice about america or its
founding you are a white supremacist
america is an evil place and we need to
undo the founding of the country and
refound the country to to take away that
that racist evil terrible root that's
rotten to the core
the second part that's funny about this
is that this woman is almost certainly
white right because you hear her say she
goes the
maybe it's fine to salute the flag if
you're one of those white
women in the suburbs but for the rest of
us who are
and then you hear there's a little pause
and so if if she's contrasting the white
people with someone else with herself
she would if she weren't white she would
probably say with who are hispanic
and blah blah or who are black and who
are but she doesn't do that she pauses
she goes yeah maybe the white people in
the suburbs will do that but not the
rest of us who are
women well hold on what women is not the
opposite of white or poor first she's
she's not poor that woman is not she
does not talk like a poor person she
talks like a a rich entitled white
liberal sushi
i can hear it i don't i'm just i don't
want to rush to conclusions but
you can hear these things
we we're oppressed
what would we be proud of in our country
and that's the question because after
decades now of teaching people that
there's nothing to enjoy about the
country nothing to be grateful for
nothing of value here that that's what
people believe that that
we we have nothing to share to people
abroad which is why now we've got to
pull everyone in from outside
but uh the country itself is rotten so
we need to bring in as many other people
who are not western who are not american
uh to help improve the country
and we need to disrespect our laws as
best we can because our laws were
founded by evil racist white supremacist
people
there is a logic
to their madness it's a it's illogic i
mean it's a perverse logic
but there is a kind of coherence in its
perversity
hey did you like that clip well if you
did please leave me a comment just just
a nice few words just say hey michael i
like that'd be very that'd be very nice
of you also head on over to wherever eh
audio podcasts whether that's apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
head on over type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five star
review and you will not miss an episode
really helps us to evade some of the
censorship that goes on in certain
places i'm just saying would love if you
would subscribe we'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you